and we are live
once again let's do it
ladies and gentlemen welcome to a
special Sunday presentation
of your favorite podcast
[Music]
[Music]
what's up y'all welcome back to
Riverwood Griffin
I'm filming a movie in Detroit this week
and there's no other time for me to do
my podcast so I got to do it right now I
just got back from Atlanta
bananas got back from Atlanta went to
the Rams game went to a wake it's just
we're here now
doing what we doing so I'm gonna do what
I said I'm recapping speak no evil I saw
Black Adam I saw wakanda forever so guys
welcome back too
[Music]
you won't know
my voice today oh it's just I've been on
a plane I've been on a plane all day and
so here we are so we're just gonna try
to make the best of it but um first off
everybody today's
podcast is brought to you by our sponsor
at better help
better help y'all that's our sponsor
better help
um
and it's the world's largest therapy
service better help has matched three
million people with professional license
and vetted therapist available 100
online plus it's affordable that's
better help
help.com Griffin
also door Dash door dash for a limited
time our listeners get 50 off up to
twenty dollar value and zero delivery
fees when you download the door Dash app
and enter code refin riffin r-i-f-f-i-n
all right what's up Chad what's up
everybody everybody thanks for watching
as you know uh welcome to riffing with
Griffin oh I didn't change the episode
number right there but we're at episode
number 210. that's what that is right
now we're at episode number
210. you know what I'm just gonna change
it right on the screen as I'm looking at
it all right so I don't like that so
let's change it to 210. Boom there we go
just like that on the Fly getting things
done
um you know so thank you for being here
make sure you subscribe share
um you know all that good stuff I know
we're slayed on a Sunday night but it is
what it is I'm on Twitch on most days
I'm on Twitch so check me out on Twitch
if you want to be a member uh you know
subscriber on Twitch
because you want to support me support
me on patreon you can also you could be
a super chat I mean a super Twitter
person I don't even know if that's still
a thing with all the weirdness going on
there patreon you could be a YouTube
member and also
a Instagram subscriber too be an
Instagram subscriber like I still got my
thing from Sofi Stadium Sofi stadium is
the most beautiful Stadium you know I
can't even get this off I gotta find
some scissors for this but anyways uh
those are all the ways you can support
me so thanks for being there and you
know
I got upcoming shows the upcoming shows
coming up actually we just play the ad
real quick here we go for my upcoming
show
[Music]
yes Wise Guys in Las Vegas November 18th
and 19th that's this weekend come check
me out at Wise Guys in Vegas it's a
great Club go to my website or Wise Guys
make vegas.wiseguys.comedy.com
[Music]
actually I thought it was gonna be an ad
but I just realized that that's just the
thing and then I do that
I was all looking like oh is the ad
gonna start and I realized oh I'm the ad
but anyways yeah so check me out there
so I'm coming to Las Vegas this weekend
18th and 19th I'm also going to be
Thanksgiving weekend Friday Saturday
Sunday I believe I'm in Addison in
Dallas so come check me out there Dallas
I'm coming your way and then the week
after that December 1st through the 3rd
I believe it is I'm in Chicago at Zanies
so come check me out I don't do this
enough with the uh recommending where
I'm coming so anyways yeah so we're here
late guys so all the people that are
here right now up late on a Sunday night
or it's not even late well for the East
Coast it's late and it's getting kind of
late here on the West Coast but thanks
for being here
um I appreciate you so
you know what I want to talk about first
I want to talk about
I I was looking at some of the comments
and I get this comment a lot sometimes
from people that maybe they know who I
am and but they've never watched the
podcast before and they just come and
they're just kind of like and I always
get the same sort of comment the same
sort of question they're always like is
this a comedy podcast like what's going
on you know um and I realized you know
what let's just be honest I got to be
honest about what this is now I don't
know if it's ever been a comedy podcast
so I'm just gonna say it right now this
isn't a comedy podcast
I'm not here to uh you know be silly and
funny I'm actually this is just a stream
of Consciousness my thoughts and
feelings about stuff that's going on in
the world I just want to give you my
point of view about what I think about
sports Entertainment News the things
that are going on even in my personal
life and and I just do it in my way I
mean I understand if you like watching
me on other things if you want to see me
be funny and that kind of stuff I have a
spot for that go watch the golden hour
with me Brendan shop crystalia we're
always being funny and silly on that
check me out on on when I've been on bad
friends when I've been on tigerbelly
when I've been with Rick Glassman and
check out Rick's Rick glassman's latest
podcast or last week so I'm not sure but
when him and I we did it live in uh
Florida so there's plenty of ways to see
me be funny go to my Instagram because
I'm putting up more stand-up Clips but
here at rip been with Griffin I'm just
riffing it's uh and I like doing it live
like this because it's unfiltered stream
of Consciousness about things that I'm
talking about and I just like doing that
I'm telling you guys I just I realize I
need to stop
pretending not that I ever was but I'm
never really verbalized it like this
I've never really verbalized it like
I've been like what am I doing here and
what I'm doing here is like I said I
like discussing things man I like
getting out these thoughts that I have
and sometimes it can be very serious or
appear serious more serious than I
normally am say like on other podcasts
and stuff or when you see me doing stand
up uh I'm a funny stand-up man I'm just
you know I'm like I'm gonna toot my own
horn I'm hilarious you will have a good
show if you come watch me do stand up
but don't but but don't think like you
looking at this late once this guy funny
or is this guy whatever this is just we
all have different sides of ourselves
we're not always serious we're not
always funny we're not always sad or
we're not always happy we're not always
hungry we're not always sleepy we have
different parts of our personality and I
like to and I'm expressing this part of
my personality on the podcast and you
know
sometimes I'm gonna be funny because of
how I'm talking about something or
sometimes I'm going to be like you know
very introspective or serious or
whatever it is like that but that's what
this is so let's Rebrand it so we know
exactly what it is I'm gonna do me so
for all the new people or old people or
people who are just confused like hey
why is the comedian being so whatever
this is this is why so we're rebranding
rebranding as the Riften with Griffin
because that's what it always was so
there it is y'all
so I went to Atlanta Atlanta was it was
all right I was competing with a lot of
stuff which I didn't realize like Adam
Sandler was in town they had a Comedy
Festival there was like another comedy
person there there was like music going
on so it was like the show I had one
good sellout show but they were all
great shows all the people out so shout
out to the punch line and all the people
out in Atlanta and I took uh my boy
David Murphy so I want to give David
Murphy a shout out he's a he's a comic
out in LA and I've known him for years I
used to coach basketball and he I used
to coach him I was a part of the
coaching staff to coach him he was a
really good basketball player in high
school and so now he's a comic and I
just took him on the road with me and
he's a he's he's super funny so he's a
somebody you should look out for on the
rise so check out David Murphy check him
out so that was good
um yeah so all right guys so I I was out
in Atlanta and uh what up what do I want
to talk about is I wait don't want to
put let me put a screen marker right
here so I know that this is the point
um
I saw some movies I saw some movies and
I was like you know what it's time to
talk about movies again because I
haven't talked about some movies in a
while
so I'm not I don't think I need to do a
spoiler alert maybe but you know I don't
know if I'm not necessarily going to
spoil the plots but these kind of movies
like there's nothing really to spoil and
at the end of the towards the last part
of the podcast if you haven't seen speak
no evil yet turn off then you should
turn off the podcast and go watch it if
you don't care you want to hear me recap
it I'm gonna do one of my recaps of like
I said from last week that movie I I
recommended speak no evil the movie I
recommended and didn't recommend I said
don't watch it but watch it because it
was just so horrifying so I'm gonna I'm
gonna just tell you everything that
happened in the movie I love doing that
maybe somebody should animate it I need
an animator out there to come out and
check me out on that
um but anyways all right so like I said
I went and watched some movies and uh
first movie
let's talk about
um Black Adam starring The Rock
where is it Black Adam so Black Adam
like on IMDb what does it say nearly 5
000 years after he was bestowed with the
almighty powers of the Egyptian gods and
in prison just as quickly Black Adam is
freed from his Earthly tomb ready to
unleash his unique form of Justice on
the modern world oh that's a nice way to
say that
so what do I think about Black Adam
um
it looked like it got like seven out of
10 on IMDb I'm not sure what the the the
Rotten Tomatoes
what the Rotten Tomatoes is with it but
uh but yeah Black Adam was uh you know
so it stars you know it stars Dwayne
Johnson and ildis Hodge and Pierce
Bronson and
um a bunch of other people
um yeah you know it was I don't know
yeah who are these people uh yeah I
don't I'd never say names right all this
or ildis Hodge I think that's the guy's
name oh Sarah Shahi or Shaha Shahi oh my
God I'm just I'm killing these names
oh Muhammad Amir he was freaking
hilarious funny story about him uh
uh Muhammad funny like I was doing um I
did this movie
yeah I'll tell you guys this story
before I even talk about Black Adam
I um
so I just I did this Ray Romano movie
Ray Romano starde wrote it he directed
it it's gonna be good he's actually a
really fantastic actor Ray Romano and he
just this his directing style was great
and so you know I get to New York
and it's like during the pandemic and so
like I have to quarantine in this hotel
for like a couple of weeks right
um
and then
I get a call and it's Ray Romano and
it's like it's so distinctly his voice
that I was like geeking out you know
what I mean because I've never met him
before and I was just like oh my God
Everybody Loves Raymond's on my phone
and he says hey man let's go out to eat
so we can go out to eat I think I've
probably even told this story before but
it doesn't matter just for everybody new
people whatever so we're out eating and
you know he says like hey man you know
you I really I know you auditioned but I
knew it was you I wanted you you were
the you were the you were the person I
wanted for this and you know he's
telling me all this lip service and I
was like cool so then it's now it's time
to shoot I'm on stat I'm in my trailer
the clothes come in and on the clothes
they have like the actor's name and it
doesn't say Eric Griffin it says
Muhammad Amir
so I go out and you know me I'm I'm that
dude so I go I'll go oh hey man I
thought I was uh the first choice
because it looked like he was like and
then he was like oh oh man he was a
local hire but then he couldn't do it
you know because it was cheaper to hire
somebody local but it was just funny
that I just called him out on it because
it was just like people love to do that
making you feel like you're special when
you're not really special but it's all
it is what it is you know what I mean
they just they made they wanted this
person he's famous famous you know and
then they couldn't get him so they go
you know what let's get let's get uh
let's get Griffin so you know that's a
story of my that's the story of my
career man so anyways Black Adam y'all
black
Adam the way we put another marker
um
I don't know what to say about this
movie here's my problem like
I just wish
like if you're gonna have
the amount of killing and violence
that's in this movie make it rated R so
you can just really do it that's my one
criticism of the movie because I gotta
tell you man Black Adam don't mess
around you know so you know the rock
like like it says like on that little
thing you know he you know he he wakes
up I won't tell you like you know the
the story about why and all that stuff
but you know you know there's you know
it's it's this sort of made-up country
and you know it goes back 5 000 years
and then you know he is mysteriously you
know woken up
um because of the other actors in the
movies some stuff that's going on and
then now he he you know comes and
there's like this like Army that's like
sort of taking over this make-believe
City
you know and and so now they need a hero
type of thing and he's sort of the
anti-hero because from jump he was he
didn't care about nobody right he was
just he was murdering people left and
right man that was his whole thing and
he's like has this sort of like god-like
Superman type powers and um
one thing I'll say about Black Adam is
it's in the DC Universe so when I say DC
Universe it's kind of like how I say you
know when you know you have Marvel
Universe all the movies are connected so
it's in the same universe this is in the
same universe of Aquaman and Ben
Affleck's Batman and and Superman and
you know so this is a Wonder Woman so
it's all part of that Universe you know
and uh the the one um constant the one
constant is what's her name who they
keep they they keep having her in every
single movie wait let me see if I can
see what is her name she was on or why
it's amazing that they're not showing
her in the in the CR in uh on the IMDb
credit but she plays Amanda Waller I
forgot what her name is
um what is her name man she was on that
show
how to get away with murder which was a
freaking phenomenal show why am I
forgetting her name and she won the
Oscar with the snot bubble in her nose
the Denzel movie come on guys and chat
you suppose anyways she's in like every
movie you know she's like this sort of
like Big Brother character so she's in
this movie too well what's the actress's
name you know
um
anyways she's in this too so that's kind
of connects all the movies uh Harley
Quinn and everybody's there Viola Davis
thank you Viola Davis yeah Savannah
Davis and she's great she's such a great
actress I like when they get really
great actors to be in these silly movies
because he brings some like authenticity
to it so anyways the rock is The Rock
and uh he's starting to look old by the
way but anyways you know so he's got
this Superman powers and he's killing
everybody and so then like the Justice
League or the Justice people these
superheroes that I've never seen before
in the in the DC Universe in the movies
are all of a sudden they're here you
know it's kind of like they're doing
this sort of Avengers thing the Marvel
thing and I kind of like it you know so
they had this guy all all this Hodge
playing Hawk man and he was funny he had
all the funny lines man he has so many
good funny lines and so the movie was
cheesy and corny I'll just say that but
it was entertaining you know like the
kid in the movie he was like he's not
the greatest actor and I think he will
be uh but like you know it's like that
sort of like corny uh you know we could
do it type of thing I you know I I
this and oh it's also connected to
Shazam by the way
because I didn't realize that that's
also in this same DC Universe because
they had another actor that's in that
movie the guy that plays the sorcerer
he's in uh this movie too so
um yeah you know I mean so there's a lot
of crossover so they're trying to create
this universe right so you know like
what do I really think of Black Adam
like I said I thought it was a little
cheesy a lot of action
um I think there's more action than
story uh but if you lack a lot of action
it's good and and I do recommend the
movie like I'm not I'm not just
completely I'm not trash in a movie I do
recommend Black Adam if you just if you
like superhero
kind of stuff and I thought The Rock was
good you know he he played it well
um he was the most grounded actually The
Rock was the most grounded actor in this
movie besides Pierce Bronson who's
always great
um yeah so it was this um
you know kind of like anti-hero becomes
the hero but not really you know and
then the the the the good guys aren't
strong enough and they need you know him
and and then it's like this sort of like
it go you know it goes back 5 000 years
and
you know and the ancestry and all this
kind of stuff and you're just kind of
like we don't when they make up a
fictional place it's kind of hard to
suspend your disbelief because in your
mind you're like they didn't really to
me they didn't really establish they
just kind of plopped you into this
universe and they're soldiers and flying
things and you're just kind of like okay
when is this is this in the future in
the past like you know is this in the
80s is this 2000s it's like it was like
a weird like you had to like really like
take a second to figure out what this
was all about but you know the
characters in it uh I think it was a
good like hey here's what we're doing in
the DC Universe now guys
um and I I like I kind of like that you
know they failed with Justice League
that was a huge failure it didn't go the
way they wanted it to go so I think this
is a nice reboot of oh let's combine all
these movies and see where we go with it
so so I was I'm interested to see like
you know where they're gonna go now at
this point this is a spoiler but it's
like if you don't there it's all this is
all over the place anyway so whatever so
finally now DC is like they're stealing
from Marvel they're like oh we gotta
have these post-credit scenes that leads
to other things in the movie so they had
they had this post-credits scene that
was so hyped up before I even went to
the movie out yeah I saw videos about it
and people were like so excited so
I don't know if you know this but
they've they've rehired Harry Oh Henry
what's his name cavizel the guy that
played Superman the current Superman in
that Universe because he had like gotten
out of his contract or something or they
they and then they were like nah we
can't do we gotta get him back so they
they signed re-signed them to a whatever
picture deal so then I read a thing that
you know so The Rock was like well we
need to do a post-credit you know we
want we want him to be in it so
apparently they had filmed it without
him and then once they got the deal then
they brought him in and and they filmed
this great post-credits scene because
you know Black Adam is like super
powerful and Amanda Waller is like you
know you better stay where you're at or
I'm gonna call in some favors and you
know and black Adam's all like well you
can't there's nobody who can stop me and
and then you know and then Superman
shows up like we need to talk I mean
that's how quick uh
the post-credit scene was but it was
kind of it you kind of got hyped up
because you're like all right so is it
going to be black Black Adam vs Superman
you know is Black Adam gonna be the hero
the villain you're just not sure so all
of that
all that made it good you know what I
mean all that made it good but Henry
cavizel yeah Henry Cavill he's a good
actor he's a really good actor I like
him as Superman the only thing I you
know what's the one thing I never liked
about him as Superman is he's too hairy
you know what I mean like I don't want
to see Superman chest hair you know I
was an arm hair or stuff like that I was
like cut that [ __ ]
um
like yeah Superman's supposed to be
smooth
silly but overall I I you know I give
Black Adams you know about maybe like
three or four woo-woos
yeah it was good
it was it was good so uh if you haven't
seen blackout in my Holly do I I
recommend it so go check it out uh I
think the rock just look and even this
picture I have up of the Rock right now
I mean The Rock how old is he because
he's he's he ain't aging well
you know what I'm saying this dude
looking old as hell so
um
go see that all right so then the other
movie I went and saw
because that's like I haven't got to see
a bunch of movies in a while I went and
saw wakanda forever
wakanda forever
but before we talk about wakanda forever
let us have a word from our sponsors
over at betterhelp.com
betterhelp.com this episode
this episode is sponsored by betterhelp
um I'm I'm all into therapy guys I'm 100
I I endorse therapy
you know it's so helpful
um
it's like people have a stigma on
therapy because you think like oh man
you think it's like that's when you're
like so you're at your worst and you
can't do anything no man I'm telling you
there when you talk to a therapist
you're talking to a professional that
recognizes patterns of behavior and
they're going to help you tap into why
you're feeling the way you're feeling
they're not going to solve your problems
but they're going to help you organize
your thoughts you can better understand
them better have some coping mechanisms
to to get you past some of the things
that you're going through in your life
stress anxiety you know you know we're
still dealing with post Covenant and how
that's made us feeling this new world
and and everything that's going on with
like you know the anti-Semitism and then
the the you know the Twitter and you
know there's so many things in our minds
that just give us stress for no freaking
reason and you know something like
better help is is helpful for you it's
the world's largest
um therapy service better help as a
match three million people with
professional licensed vetted their
purpose available 100 online plus the
main part about this it's affordable
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
match with a therapist if things are
clicking you can easily switch if things
aren't clicking you know you can easily
switch which is that type of important
thing man you don't have to be stuck
with a therapist that's why online
therapy is great because sometimes when
you go to an office you feel like oh man
now I'm stuck with this person you don't
you don't have to feel like that there's
no waiting rooms no traffic no endless
searching for the right therapist learn
more and save 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com Griffin that's better
help
h-e-l-p.com slash Griffin I recommend it
also today's episode is brought to you
by door Dash door Dash
um you know when you want to get
something to eat you don't want to go
out or you haven't shopped or you're on
the move you're on the go are you just
feeling lazy today doordash is the spot
for you you got back-to-back meetings
you got errands to run you got chores to
do or maybe even went to the market and
you forgot some stuff door Josh is the
one for you you ever pull into your
driveway after a trip to the grocery
store like I say and you're like oh man
I forgot that so and so doordash you hit
them up for that kind of stuff last
minute school supplies you need soaps
things like that it's not all just food
doordash does a lot of stuff all right
along with restaurants you love you can
now get groceries and other essential
items delivered to doordash get drinks
snacks other household items in under an
hour with over 300 000 Partners you can
support your neighborhood go to
and you could choose from so many
different plays your favorites National
chains plus those little mom paw shops
around your place that you want to help
love doordash for a limited time our
listeners get 50 off up to 20 value and
zero delivery fees when you download the
doordash app and enter code riffin
that's 50 off up to twenty dollar value
and zero delivery fees when you download
the doordash app in the app store and
enter code riffin that's r-i-f-f-i-n
don't forget that's code written for 50
off up to twenty dollar value and zero
delivery fees with doordash subject to
change terms apply
all right let's get to
um wakanda forever
um to the chat did y'all see wakanda all
right first off I'ma say this
I didn't like the first black panther
okay I just didn't like I thought it was
cheesy and corny there were so many
things I didn't like about it I thought
that Chadwick Bozeman's character in The
Civil War movie outside of a black
panther I thought it was a stronger more
more driven character and then Black
Panther the movie he just was like what
happened to him I just didn't like the
story I didn't like the movie I didn't
like I didn't like how they what they
did with the villain I just didn't like
that the story had so many holes I
didn't like it but that was the white
guilt movie of the year so you know
black panther was like Hamilton you know
a lot of non-black people had to be like
oh my God this was so great oh did you
see black panther it was so good you
know it's like nah it wasn't okay it
wasn't now this movie
so much better
I
thoroughly enjoyed wakanda forever more
than I thought I was going to
it was
it was it had a great story it was great
acting it you know you cared about what
was happening the villain was great I
like when like you can empathize with
the villain you know when you just go
well this dude's just trying to he got
family and he got you know people he
care about that's why he's do you know
even if it's misguided you
when you can
feel for the villain that makes it hard
in the movie to be like ah what do you
want to happen and they did an excellent
job with that they did an excellent job
um it's just you know and then the main
girl what's her name uh latita right I
think she's the star a Lupita na young
why do I always pick
the movies with the names I can never
pronounce it's like I sound like a
freaking idiot but you you know what I'm
talking about this the stars of the
movie you know let me go to the other
screen for people that are watching
people that are listening you know just
go to IMDb right now and take a look at
it but like these were all
you know and you know you have to
suspend your disbelief you know it's one
of those movies where like the you know
the girls are beating everybody up even
though like it makes sense I saw this
video this this black woman who was like
going in about like you know
the emasculating of the black men in
this movie and why they're making it
seem like these women get beat up
everybody and stuff it's like it's a
freaking movie Man suspend your
disbelief they train in wakanda you know
what I mean they got the the spears that
you know made from that metal and you
know you know what I'm saying they got
Nanobots and it's like you got to
suspend your disbelief and then the main
chick you know she's she takes the Black
Panther potion so it's like you know
what I mean that's why she's super
strong and all that kind of stuff it's
like it is what it is I always used to
think the only thing I never like about
the Black Panther universe is why are
they only giving this to one person if
you got all these you know before the
the uh
um the whatever the bad guy is but
Michael P Jordan played
for he burned it all up you know you'd
be like why won't y'all just have like
10 10 black panther guys it didn't make
any sense to me but you know it was
showing tradition and honor and like so
I get that part of it too but um
you know you after you suspend your
disbelief then you just go with it man
uh Angela Bassett was terrific in this
man there was so many great scenes
of just actors man like that the
actresses talking with each other it was
some great moments and you know what it
is it's like I love comic book movies
and I love action but I'm also an
artistic nerd too and I love
good dialogue and interactions on the
screen people really feeling emotions
and you know what
the best ones for that is when you add
women more it's like women really bring
that to these things because it's
because when you're making a all-male
movie about action movies and stuff it's
kind of hard to find uh the moments to
really give you that emotions that's
what made Robert Downey Jr so great as
Iron Man he's so great at Iron Man
because he really was like you you
believed him like like in that there was
that great scene in Infinity War where
you know
um Captain Marvel brings him back and
he's all emaciated with his you know and
he's he's yelling at Captain America you
know what I mean you you're a liar you
know that scene was so powerful because
he was you he was bringing it like that
right he's one of the few actors in that
series that brought that I wish it was
more of that everyone else is just like
kind of cool and like I gotta be cool
cool you know or funny or fake funny you
know like Thor
um but but like I enjoyed Black Widow do
you got to watch Black Widow Black Widow
is that is a great movie and the
actresses in that they are bringing it
and it just adds to the action so it's
great action and then this great uh
story and dialogue that's what I thought
wakanda brought wakanda forever I
thought it was just it was really
fantastic I'm like I'm really shocked at
how much I enjoyed this movie especially
just thinking about how I did not like
the first movie so again like I I really
uh you know I really recommend this and
I mean there was some holes in it
there's some stuff in the story that are
they they didn't explain some things
like there's this girl who like makes an
Iron Man outfit you see no spoiler here
because it's in a trailer you could see
you don't know who she is who is she
where she come from like who is she in
the universe you know you're just like
okay why does she you know why is she
brilliant you know like why where where
was This brilliant person when all that
other stuff was going on and then
there's a couple things like
and I feel this way about all the Marvel
movies that are connected to the MCU
if an event is going on in the universe
you can't
now we're like where's Thor
you know where's Captain America where's
uh you know Hulk where's where are these
people where's She-Hulk now like when
all this stuff is going on in wakanda
and like you know you you kind of you
want to be like where is everybody
where's Daredevil now he's a part of it
now too you know it's like where's
everybody
you know
um and they did this they honored
Chadwick Bozeman in a great way you know
they really you know it's like what are
you supposed to do you do you end the
franchise you know so they they opened
the movie with like he's dying and he
dies you know and the way they did it I
thought was well done
um and then they cut they really honored
him in the in the credits and and
throughout the movie you you got a sense
of like oh this guy was like like I felt
like they were talking about him the
actor not even
black panther or or the king t'challa
whatever they call them you know like I
thought they did a good job honoring his
legacy
um uh you know that was really good I
don't know you know this is just me you
know this is what I think about it you
know so I thought that that was I
thought it was good
um but like I say you know I think you I
felt like you cared about the main
characters I thought you cared about the
villain
um you know you you cared about the
universe and what was going to happen
and and leading to the whatever is going
to happen next and you know because you
know it's all connected because they had
um what's her face uh
um Elaine from Seinfeld was in it what's
her name Lewis Something Dreyfus or dry
what I always forget her name and why
isn't it on the IMDb damn dude and she's
like in the other movies you know
she's in like she's into TV shows she
was in Hawkeye TV show she was in the
Captain America TV show she was in
another you know she's around like so
she's the Specter of you know Doom and
Gloom or something that's going on so
she kind of like is the through line
that connects all of these universes the
television shows plus the the the the
the the
um
you know the um movies and you know
you're interested to see I mean I saw a
great thing about like you know because
they because they're setting up the
Young Avengers too because you got the
girl from Hawkeye the show she's gonna
be a young Avenger you got ant-man's uh
daughter young Avenger you might even
have Iron Man's daughter could get
involved you got
um there's so many the young Loki
um that's supposed to be somebody
they've introduced a couple of
characters oh uh Wanda's kids because
also the girl from uh you know
um doctor strange that can jump through
universes you know she's one of the you
know so they got a little crude I mean
um I was kind of like I remember saying
that I thought the MCU was dead
I I thought so because of some bad
movies that came out right but I think
that they can resurrect it I think they
can take us in a new place let's see
what's going on with shangji the
eternals let's see what's going on with
like this whole Daredevil cap Daredevil
she-hawk Hawk
all this crossover stuff let's see what
happens and and after seeing this movie
I was like oh they can still make great
movies they can still make great movies
so
yeah so I don't know guys I I give this
like a lot of woo-woo's
[Music]
it was great great movie great movie
with counting forever super thumbs up on
wakanda forever all right guys Now's the
Time now is the time okay let me tell
you right now if you want to see the
movie speak no evil
if you want to watch that movie
and you you want to see the the the
surprise and all the stuff that I'm
talking about that goes on with the
movie Now's the Time for you to check
out of the podcast thank you for
watching please subscribe and share and
and uh you know come back and watch
finish off but now is the time spoiler
alert I'm giving it to you right now
spoiler alert
I'm gonna now recap the entire movie
speak no evil
okay so it's I believe it's Dutch or
Danish it's one of those I'm one of
these idiots that always thought Dutch
and danish were the same thing right but
it's not
so
the movie opens up it like it's like
some sort of like wedding or it's some
sort of summer party and there's a bunch
of people there family and there's a
couple of couples there okay so the main
couple is this guy uh his name is you
know what I don't know how do you say
these Dutch names but whatever his name
is
born or you know and his wife Luis okay
and they have a daughter all right uh oh
you don't even they don't even have a
picture of her uh oh this they do her
name is Agnes so they have their little
daughter Agnes
played by this actress and she was great
okay so they're they're going on a
vacation right and so they're at this
thing and it's like a wedding okay and
so it's these two and you can tell that
their marriage is kind of like it's a
little iffy you know like maybe they've
been married and now they have this kid
and and it hasn't gone quite the way the
the guy wanted it to go and he's kind of
a [ __ ] for being honest and that's
that's important for the story you know
it's kind of like this like he's not
he's not living his full life and his
full potential he gives you that sense
that he's and and he has a daughter that
he obviously loves he you know you you
kind of feel like he loves his wife I
don't know and uh you know and then and
then they meet another couple so they
meet this couple this guy who Patrick
and Karen okay
they meet this couple and they have a
kid
a bell right they had this other little
kid they have a kid a son
and then the kid can't talk you know so
they're saying hey here's our son he's
got a speech thing so he's not gonna
talk a lot right
and then the couples kind of hit it off
you know it's you know you ever meet
it's like they meet each other they're
at this event they're having a good time
and so they go their separate ways and
then the Patrick and Karen they I
believe send a note to them because they
kept in contact and said hey come to our
little cottage and visit us you can stay
with us and so they think about it and
then the couple goes all right let's do
it they got a kid the same age as our
daughter let's go and go and then the
movie starts to get weird because when
they get there the dude Patrick says
he's a doctor so they think he's a
doctor okay but he's sort of a weird
eccentric guy and some so so like
there's sort of like some weird Behavior
going on the little son is like acting
he's acting weird you know but you think
oh okay he can't speak so that's why
he's acting like that right so then the
movie sort of goes on and it's like a
slow burn of like these sort of weird
things that that this guy Patrick is
saying and he's kind of a he's a he's a
little he's inappropriate you know he's
like getting a little like not handsy
but the things that he's saying is
making the wife the other wife played by
Luis so we got born in Luis they're the
couple with their daughter and then you
got Patrick and Karen they're the weird
sort of strange couple that invited them
out so
cut to where you know the mom is just
kind of very protective of her daughter
you know like there's a scene where the
the the daughter loses her stuffed
animal and she's like you know where is
my little whatever you know it's like
whatever's bunny I need you know
whatever this stupid name for the doll
was like where is it you know so the dad
is like all right you know the dad's
kind of like I mean let's sorry you lost
it but then the mom's looking at him
like I mean we got to get it and he's
like okay you know so he goes searching
around the city where they were and he
finds it brings it back she's like yay
now she loses this [ __ ] three
times okay it's like yo take care of
your dog your your toys you know what
I'm saying like take care of your toys
because we about to get murdered and you
messing around losing your toys anyway
so
like I said this couple is starting to
act weird right weird and then
they go all right let's go out and the
mom the mom Louise she's a little like
helicopter mom for Agnes the little girl
so the uh the other parents are like
well let's go out okay let's go out to
uh to to a local pub because they they
were they're in the countryside you know
so there's not a lot of people around
there's not a lot of other houses like
maybe the next house is like an acre or
two away so it's that kind of thing and
it's like a you know Forest Road to get
everywhere so so then
the um the parents go yeah so you know
we leaving them here the kids and the
mom's like wait what they're not coming
and then a babysitter walks in and it's
a dude right it's just some random dude
okay and then you know you know we live
in a society where like when you think
babysitter it should be a woman that's
just our thought process and I think
they did that on purpose so you kind of
like even as a viewer you kind of
getting a little weirded out you're like
okay hold on a second well you gotta you
got a dude watching my daughter hold on
but then the dude comes in and he's like
doing magic tricks and then the little
girls laughing and the mom's looking
like I don't know this dude you know but
then the husband's kind of like I think
everything's fine babe let's go out you
know what I mean like he's like I'm
tired of being a dad let's go out and
have some fun for once all right so then
the mom is still a little leery of the
guy but the guy is very disarming and
you kind of like him too as a viewer
because you're like oh okay this dude's
fine let me you know what let me get my
get these preconceived notions out of my
head what am I doing you know what I
mean I'm being weird too as a viewer I
was thinking that right so they get in
the car and then you know this guy she's
acting again he's acting weird you know
what I mean he acting weird and so they
get to the the pub right
and there's nobody there it's just them
and and the person that works at the pub
you know so then you know they're
dancing and they're saying weird things
and then like the Patrick and Karen they
get up on the dance floor and they're
practically having sex on the dance
floor in front of these two just the way
they were it was like and so then the
other two were kind of feeling like well
I guess I mean should we uh You Wanna
Dance for it so they kind of get on the
dance floor but they're not doing it as
quite as whatever okay this is this is
what I'm saying about weird Behavior so
then they're trying to leave they're
gonna leave and it's time to pay the
bill you know and so the the guy Patrick
he's looking at the dude he's like yeah
you know we gotta pay the bill you know
what I mean and uh the the the other guy
the the main guy born is like wait hold
on he's like wait
um oh you know it's a kind of vibe where
like I invite you to dinner and then I'm
looking at you to like split the bill
and then
so the guy's like okay
I guess all right he pulls out his
credit card and then the Patrick guy
goes oh thanks man I appreciate that and
walks away then the other guy's like
wait I'm paying so the guy paid so the
guests paid the bill
the goo Patrick's drunk not a driving
home okay they're driving home and he's
like swerving he's driving drunk they're
he's playing the music loud but now he's
he's in like a he don't give a freak
mood you know and the music's too loud
and then the wife's like ask him to turn
it down and you know he won't turn it
down and he's like being all he's being
all Annoying Annoying playful but he's
being aggressive you know he's like go
I'm turning it up you know then the wife
is like turn that [ __ ] music down you
know the the other wife you know and
then like the wife in the front's like
oh I'm sorry he's just being whatever
okay so they get back to the house the
white now the mom is already kind of
like we need to go home like this is
some weird that this I don't like these
people you know what I mean and I got
the same Vibe too as watching I was like
I don't like these people at all or if
you're just getting here I told you this
is a spoiler alert I told you like 10
minutes ago when I started this I'm
telling you the whole movie I I gave
plenty of spoiler alerts it's in the
title spoilers so I'm recapping the
movie
like it or not this is what it is okay
so now
the dudes whatever so now the wife is
all like I just you know she's freaking
out about this guy and she's got a Vibe
of like she wants to go home so then
like so she goes I'm gonna go take a
shower so she goes in to take a shower
right she's in the shower and then you
hear the door open
door opens
for the thing and then you hear a man
peeing you know
and it's to do the the you know the
Patrick guy so he just bursts into the
bathroom while she's in here but that's
naked in the shower peas and then they
do this great scene where like her
back's to the door and she's just kind
of like you know and then he's just like
in the steam you know what I mean like
in the door looking at her and then he
leaves so now she's all like we gotta
get the hell out of here
so then the husband's like all right we
can leave tomorrow you know so they're
in bed together right
so they hear them being like whatever
then her daughter starts to
call for her because the daughter sleeps
in their bed you see that earlier the
daughter is like kind of like [ __ ]
blocking all the time so these two start
to like kiss and they you know they
start to have sex so they start to have
sex but the daughter is like Mama
mama can where are you Mom you know
they're doing that and they're like okay
chill [ __ ] we're coming you know what I
mean literally trying to come like okay
shut up they gave they give her kind of
like that kind of attitude and then
they're having sex so they start having
sex this couple and uh the the the the
the the visitors you know and then again
the weird Patrick guy
for some reason he's got a window he
could see right inside their room so he
looks in he's like yeah you know he's
looking at him having sex like all right
okay so now
the the couple finishes having sex and
they're kind of laying there so the mom
gets up to go check on her daughter she
goes into the room to check on her
daughter and her daughter's not there
okay
she goes in looking for her and she goes
into their bedroom Patrick and Louise
and the daughter is laying in bed with
them
and the covers the sheet is off of
Patrick he butt ass naked y'all
butt ass naked him his wife is into the
sheets and then their their daughter you
imagine you walk into a room you don't
know where your daughter is you stay
with strangers
you you don't you can't find your
daughter your little 10 year old 11 year
old daughter you walk into a room
and you see a naked man is laying in the
bed with his wife and your daughter so
the mom is like oh no
so she grabs her daughter she goes
inside the room you know and she's like
honey we gotta leave I want to leave now
you know what I mean get your [ __ ] let's
get out of here you know what I'm saying
it's kind of early morning whatever what
right you know and um
so
they get all their [ __ ] together and
they start driving away you know what I
mean you think oh wow that was crazy
you know yeah that the child was in the
bed with the strangers y'all I'm looking
at the chat too I'm trying to all right
so they driving away guess what the
little daughter where's my toy you know
the little stuffed animal where's like
she had a name for it I forgot the name
but we'll just call it bunny for now
because I can't remember the name
where's bunny you know and they're just
and the mom's like [ __ ] Bunny's gone
you know what I'm saying the mom is all
like listen we but we're gonna get you
another one and then she's like you know
she's crying it's like it's okay because
the other son oh and then the other son
was acting weird all the other son is
weird the sun is just a weird kid okay
so the dad is now like you know
all right hold on a second
I gotta get my daughters so they turn
back
and they try to sneak into the house so
so the doc the dad's like all right
y'all wait here I'm gonna go get this
doll
he goes in and then the daughter's like
oh I found it you know it was under the
seat I'm like [ __ ]
so then
the mom has to go in to try to get the
hey we gotta get out of here now the the
main couple's up you know Patrick and
Karen are up like yo what happened why
are you guys leaving
and then they're just kind of like hey
you know
you were acting weird last night you you
you did some really inappropriate stuff
and then the dude is super apologetic
man he's all like oh well I'm sorry oh
you know I didn't mean to make you feel
that way and uh you know I got too drunk
and then and they're being like you go
okay they trying to be remorseful right
and then the mom is like
in the moment that they being remorseful
the mom was like yeah you also have my
daughter in your bed naked okay so and
he's like oh well you know I'm sorry but
like she was calling for you
you know because he knew they was in
there [ __ ]
you know what I mean so he's all like
yeah but you know your daughter was
calling for you calling for you calling
for you and y'all didn't do nothing why
why didn't you come get her so we just
we we had to get her you know we had you
know and so then they made them feel bad
so the parents were kind of like oh yeah
well I guess we did kind of leave our
daughter you know because we were trying
to have our moment so then the Patrick
Guy starts being like nice and he's like
I'm sorry you know what I mean can I
play music he's being all like you know
I'm so sorry and whatever and then he
kind of befriends the the uh the the the
other husband you know he's making that
he's like hyping the husband up they get
into a hot tub together he's all like
making him feel like oh you the man you
the man he takes them over to this like
um
this kind of like uh what do you call
this Stone area where you have like
stones that you use for building it's
like a quarry okay and then he's like
you know what you need to do man you
need to just yell it out so he makes the
Guy Yell he gets out his frustration
because he can see like you know this
dude's not happy with his life he's like
a [ __ ] you know what I'm saying like he
really like the dude Patrick's like come
on man like man up he's like you know
you gotta you know enjoy your life okay
so now now this is where the movie this
is towards the end of the movie and this
is all a slow burn right so now they're
back at the house okay so the kids the
kids go hey
the daughter's like hey can we come
dance for you guys you know oh even
before that though they're having dinner
right and the mom the other mom the
daughter is sitting there doing some
stuff and the other mom's kind of like
being like yeah um you know don't do
that uh yeah yeah she's trying to teach
she's telling her what to do right and
then and then the main mom the Louise
she's like hey stop telling my daughter
what to do you know and they're like
okay sorry like she's getting weird now
she wants to leave again because she's
like this is getting weird this is too
weird right
that kind of stuff was going on so you
cut two now the kids want to dance for
them all right so now they're in the
living room and the kids are dancing
okay
um oh see I'm leaving something now
earlier in the movie the kids were
playing on a a slide like that a jungle
like at a park and there's a slide and
the little boy was on the bottom of the
slide and the girl up top would wanted
to slide down and the kid wouldn't move
he was just sitting there because he's a
little weirdo right he's just sitting
here and then you know the mom goes over
to the other mom and dad goes hey you
know she wants to slide can you ask the
kid to leave the dad goes over an
aggressively moves his kid like grabs
him and he's like shaking him and he's
like what are you doing you know and
they're like yo it's okay it's not that
serious so he's aggressive with his son
that's what I wanted to establish too
he's aggressive with his son all right
cut two Nails towards the end of the
movie The kids are dancing in the living
room they're trying to dance they're
terrible especially the boy he's off
rhythm you know what I mean
and not appearance the dad's all like
what are you doing you know and he's
being super aggressive with his son like
like come on do it right you know and he
gets up and he grabs him and he's like
do it again you know another little girl
is scared and the other parents are like
yo you can't talk to your kid like that
what are you doing and they're like hey
don't tell us how to raise our kid and
then you know it's like super awkward
and weird like I'm out you know what I
mean like once my daughter is naked in
my daughter is in a bed with a naked a
naked man I'm already out she don't get
the stuffed animal back you understand
what I'm saying so that like I'm already
like these people are already making bad
choices okay so now they they they being
real aggressive with their son and
they're like dancing again do it again
you know and so now this parents are
like we gotta get out of here okay we
got to get out of here so now they get
all the [ __ ] they get in the car and
they're just like let's go let's go
let's go they try to take off right
something happens to the car you know
I forgot a really important part that's
where they gotta leave okay
now the father
he's like this place is weird
something's going on he's telling his
wife like something weird here we gotta
get out of here so now he's going like
he's exploring okay
in their house
he goes into it he finds a room with
there's a bunch of pictures on the wall
all right
pictures of them this couple that lived
this weird couple
and other couples and the kids
but what he sees is he sees a picture of
the couple and a different kid
and then he sees another couple next to
them and their current son
but this son that's with them is with
this other couple
and the wall is littered with pictures
like that you can actually follow a
train where it's like there's a kid who
was with another couple is now with them
and then the next picture is a different
kid you know what I mean and now the
dude is like freaked out
and he goes to where the hot tub was and
he sees their son is dead in the hot tub
the other the the people's son so now
the dad is like oh [ __ ] we gotta get out
of here because these people are crazy
he thinks they killed their own kid so
he grabs you know they get in the car
they trying to drive away right
something happens to the car so now the
dad is like all right
y'all stay here there's a house imma go
he can't find anybody when he comes back
his family's not there
then the couple shows up you know
this is the part
that is
crazy
the couple pulls up no gun no bat no
weapons just aggressive behavior like
get out of the car he's like what what's
going on what are you doing he freaking
punches him he's like get in the car you
know so he he gets in the car and they
do I'm like dude what are you doing
because his family's going down so he's
like where's my family all right so you
think maybe he's trying to find out
about the family so they get over to
where the family is
they tell him to get in the car
you know
so they got the daughter
the husband's in the front their two
husbands are in the front seat the women
are in the back seat you know and then
the other wife is all like trying to
grab the girl and then the mom's like
get away from my daughter you know so
then they pull up to a spot and then you
know the the Patrick Duke he keeps
punching it he's punking him so the dad
is in the front just kind of like just
do what they say and I'm like Yo dude do
something for your freaking family
and this is what happens man so even if
now I've told you spoiler alert this
whole time huge spoiler right here this
is the most terrifying horrific thing
I've ever seen in a movie I'm about to
tell you right now
the babysitter guy I was telling you
about
he comes
to the car door
opens the car door
grabs the wife pulls her out of the way
is leaning in over the wife
grabs the little girl
and jams her mouth open
the other mom takes some scissors
and cuts off the daughter's tongue
I said it
like what [ __ ]
she cuts off
the little girl's tongue
and then
the babysitter dude grabs the little
girl and takes her away
the mom is like
she's yelling for her daughter
you know and then the mom the other
mom's like shut up you know and the
dad's in the front just kind of like oh
my God and they you know the guy's
punching him
then
they drive them to this stone quarry
that he went to before
he takes them there he's like why are
you doing this and the other guy says
because I can just like that why am I
doing it because I can't he don't got no
weapon nothing there's no gun to their
head these two are just weak ass that's
why he did it he's like I'm doing this
because I can because y'all ain't gonna
do [ __ ] it's basically the vibe he had
he tells him to strip down naked their
daughter has been taken y'all and her
tongue has been cut off
he takes him to the stone quarry
he makes them go down into the stone
quarry and then him and the wife
start throwing
rocks this size
he just they just start throwing rocks
at him
and they they kill them they they they
they stoned them to death
and then that's the end of the movie
that's the end of the movie dude man
I don't even know if I'm doing a job if
I even did it justice but it's a slow
burn with subtitles because sometimes
it's English sometimes it's not and it's
just weird moment after weird moment
where you're saying to yourself Yo
hey
get your kid and get out of here
and they just don't
and it oh
they cut off the daughter's tongue
the [ __ ] was crazy
it was crazy
it was crazy
I regret watching the movie but at the
same time I needed to see it but anyways
that is uh the recap of speak no evil as
promised I said I was gonna do it and so
I did it so there it is all right
um
let's see where we at now what have I
not played for you guys in a while
so yeah
so now we at the wrap recap I want to
thank everybody for watching riffing
with Griffin make sure you subscribe
share hit me up on Twitch
and I'll always be there for you yeah
yeah yeah yeah
oh it's riff of Griffin
with the recap
oh
Step Up Get slap
[Music]
oh yeah oh yeah
assault Black Adam
I don't have words that word with Adam
but it was good
Joy
is it it had to rock
it's like a star
it always goes High
cause the Rocks off the Fly Guy
wakanda forever
ever and ever
[Music]
like Robert Horry shooting threes
like Rick Dees that movie got you on
your knees
you going Eric Griffin please
[Music]
what's your STEEZ inside
rap recap
you know it's never what
that's how we do it
oh speak now people want some crazy [ __ ]
I can't believe the parents would end up
in the ditch
after they were born
crazy ass vacation
don't ever do it
[Music]
oh oh
give me a pound and some rap
me on the back
[Music]
taking over the set
running [ __ ] like I'm over fat
wanna get kept
everybody thanks for watching thanks for
listening thanks for sharing Super Chat
special Sunday night
and we're doing it right
you next week
With A New Beat
look at me [ __ ] tap on my feet
with Griffin
yeah thanks for watching
I'll see you next week
if you ever beat you can send it to me
at ericgriffin.com
put it rap recap beat
and it might make the show thanks for
watching and I'll see you next week
[Music]